Olivia goes you want that Super Bowl
okay
mr. Edelman and all that yes my morning
monstery comes from Kavita Davidson a
righty and Bloomberg view she's writing
quote in both cases it's hard not to
suspect that the brief amount of time
taken to evaluate the player means the
outcome was predetermined she is talking
here about Julian Edelman being in
appearing to be injured he's the New
England Patriots receiver in the Super
Bowl game it looked like he may have had
a serious blow to the head but he
continued to play the other incident
she's talking about is when Russell
Wilson a few weeks ago took a block from
from the paper was it what she's saying
is if yet another way the NFL is using
controlled messaging to persuade us its
biggest problems are being handled when
the only real thing being handled is us
so I thought there was what was
interesting to me watching the game was
the way NBC reported assiduously
blow-by-blow sorry to use a bad metaphor
on what was happening with the
concussion protocol they kept on using
the words concussion protocol and that
was very clearly something that they
were being fed by the NFL this is
exactly what we're doing they made such
a big deal out of it in a way that you
don't ever see in a football game but I
think the other news to watch you know
there's there's what happened on Sunday
and then there's right now I'm looking
at news February 3rd NFL's concussion
pack blocked as insufficient so the city
you know the US District Judge Anita
Brody in Philadelphia said that she's
not going to improve that 375 million
dollar settlement she still wants to
sort of look at better payouts better
terms for some of the players so this is
not behind the NFL she's also saying
she's questioning the new statistics
that the NFL is putting out reporting
that concussions decreased by 25% it
could be anecdotal it doesn't really
look like a scientific survey and it's
just the latest headache for I can state
unequivocally hockey's change they
they're they have they have said if you
hit a guy in the head you're gonna sit
on X number game somebody on the Bruins
just got a 40,000 per game penalty what
about the enforcer culture is that
changing it's a little bit changing but
to football you know I agree with you it
was a somewhat of a fiction ballet yes
think about how many professional
footballers come out and say they won't
let their own children play football
yeah tell you something very much it's a
huge
I mean would you let your kids play you
know I talked to so my so my cousin
played Division one football and he said
he he's not worried about he would let
his kids play the real difference he
says is between college and the pros
there's so much bigger there's so much
faster it's so much more dangerous he's
fine with college ball and and would put
a cap on it after that